Let me walk you through this calculation because if you're like me log base two
numbers aren't something that you can do in your head and
it can be kind of hard to find a calculator that can handle them.
I'm gonna let Python do the heavy lifting for me.
So I go into Python and I import the math module.
So I want negative Pi times log base two of Pi.
So I do negative Pslow is 0.5 times log 0.5.
If I put the second argument here, the two that tells you the base of
the log to use, so since I need log base two, I put a two there.
If I wanted log base 10, I would put a 10 there, and so on.
And then I need to add in a second term, so
this takes care of pslow, I also have a contribution from pfast.
Remember, I need to sum over all the classes that are available.
So, Pslow and Pfast happen to be the same.
So this is pretty easy, just type it again.
And the entropy, as it turns out, is 1.0.
So this is the maximally impure state, right.
We have two class labels that are available to us.
And I get an entropy of 1.0.
So remember, the largest that we could get, the largest value for
the entropy that we could get was 1.0.
This means that, this is the maximally impure sample that we could have.
If we have two class labels, the most impure situation we could
have is where the examples are evenly split between the two class labels, so
the entropy of the starting node is 1.0